next question hey David if Pete Buddha
judge wins Iowa could he win the
nomination even if he never takes the
lead in national polling this is a very
interesting question so if you look at
national polling right now as of as of
this recording Buddha judges polling
just under 8 percent now that doesn't
sound like much but it does represent a
close to doubling of Pete Buddha judges
polling if you go back just a few months
P blue to judge was polling as low as
about 4% he's at nearly 8 percent so
certainly his national support has
increased
he has been helped as we talked about
earlier by MSNBC's choice to give him
way more talk time than his polling
level would dictate if talk time
correlates with polling support but this
is an election that is a bunch of
primaries it is not one national
election so let's look at the states if
you look at Iowa Pete Buddha judge
according to the last four polls is
leading in Iowa and he surged to take
the lead over Elizabeth Warren Bernie
Sanders and Joe Biden Warren Sanders and
Biden depending on which poll you look
at are between second and fourth Pete
Buddha judges in the lead what about New
Hampshire if you go over it to New
Hampshire right now Pete Buddha judge
has made a significant gain in New
Hampshire but is not as of now in the
lead technically still in third place
although within the margin of error
ahead of Bernie behind Warren and Biden
then you go to Nevada which is primary
number three and in Nevada Budaj edge at
this point appears to have no chance
whatsoever he's polling around five to
nine and remember that if you don't get
15% you don't get any delegates
whatsoever
so Nevada as of now shaping up to be a
zero for Buddha judge and then when you
look at South Carolina the first of the
four primaries that has more minority
voters Pete Buddha judge also very far
behind in fourth place with as little as
3 percent support in one of the most
recent polls so if Pete Buddha judge
wins Iowa can he win the nomination it
is not obvious to me but he also is
still in this thing there are people who
are big
supporters who are making the case that
he is sort of on an Obama like
trajectory for late gain and that even
if he's not winning right now in Nevada
and South Carolina if he takes Iowa
that's going to help him in New
Hampshire if he takes Iowa and New
Hampshire that's going to get him
momentum and help him in Nevada and then
at least he might be able to get some
delegates out of South Carolina even as
unlikely as it might be that he wins
there the answer is yeah he could win
but it is a significantly uphill battle
compared to Biden Warren and Bernie who
are currently in a position where if
their elections today mirrored their
polling today they would get delegates
pete Budaj in a number of these states
would get 0 delegates because he's not
polling 15% which is required to get any
delegates Iowa's a little different
because it's a caucus where there are
sort of subsequent rounds of
consolidating support we don't have to
get into the details of that so if you
are a Buddhist supporter and you are
holding out hope yes he could still win
the nomination and this is why I've said
it does make sense for him to be in the
debates it doesn't make sense for a lot
of the other people who are in the
debates to be in the debates if you are
not a Buddha judge supporter it is still
the most likely scenario that he does
not secure the nomination but it was
unlikely that Trump was going to secure
the nomination at one point as well so
let's not read more into that than is
warranted he's in this thing and if he
does win Iowa it will no doubt be a
boost to his campaign